it's Monday morning at 9 a.m. and
secondary schools in England have just
reopened their gates to students in
years 10 and 12 I've been looking
forward to this moment for 13 long weeks
since that frightening afternoon in
March when my colleagues and I gathered
around a computer in the staff room and
saw a healthier-looking Boris Johnson
declare he was shutting schools but
today I'm not at the comprehensive and
hackneyed where I teach economics
welcoming back my students with a
rousing lesson on the financial
devastation caused by the crisis
I'm surplus to requirements and I'm
still marooned at home what reopening
means is that a mere one-quarter of year
10 about 40 students have turned up to
school where they will have a short day
and learn mainly maths English and
science my school like every other in
the land has followed government orders
and done a gold-plated risk assessment
to ensure these students will be safe
it's laid out rules covering the
movement of every teenager for every
second of the truncated day that they'll
spend there with barely 40 of them in at
any given time occupying a space built
for 750 the risk of anyone picking up
the virus must be smaller than of them
falling down stairs and cracking their
heads on the tiled floor below it must
be far lower than the risk of acquiring
Cove at 19 at Tesco or Primark and in a
different league of magnitude to the
risk of having picked her up last
weekend on nearby London fields were the
crowds of picnickers revelers and
drinkers reminded me of Glastonbury
while the health danger to these few
students of returning to school is
miniscule the risk to the others of
staying at home in their bedrooms where
they've been incarcerated for three
months on Google classroom or similar is
monumental today instead of being able
to do the part of my job that I love
being in a real classroom with real
children I'm sitting at home staring at
some slides I've just made and talking
to my computer stop the video now I'm
saying
and write down the definition of fiscal
policy I'm trying to make my voice sound
light and cheery but my heart is heavy
there are 25 students in this particular
class 8 of them will listen carefully
and follow my instructions to a tee a
further eight will do the work more
sloppily the rest will not do it at all
there has been much talk about how the
closure of schools has widened the gap
in educational achievement the eight
students who will watch my video and
pause every time I say pause are the
same eight I had no worries about before
the virus struck summer middle class
children and most the girls but all have
a rock-solid work ethic and are well
supported by their parents the students
doing nothing of the same students I was
fretting about from the moment I started
teaching them many a poor some have
behavioral difficulties some have
complicated special needs for most it's
a Herculean job to get them to work at
the best of times even with the strict
structure provided by the school none of
them has done a single sausage since
this nightmare began for every week of
lockdown all teachers at my school fill
in a spreadsheet to track the students
who are not working a drop-down menu
gives the option behind with work but
this doesn't quite cover it it's not
just that they're behind with new
content but by September they will have
forgotten all the old and more
importantly they will have lost work
habits that the school has been
painstakingly instilling since their
first day in year 7 according to the
Sutton trust the damage done to
educational inequality from closing
schools has undone the work not of a
term but of a decade not only as the gap
widening between students in my class
it's widening between north and south
rich and poor and between state and
private schools research by UCL's
Institute of Education shows that in the
southeast 28% of kids are working more
than a four hours a day compared to less
than 10
% in the Northeast the children on free
school meals are half as likely to be
working hard as richer ones and over 30%
of private schools are offering four or
more hours of lessons a day five times
as many as state schools laptops people
have been crying the poorest kids don't
have laptops or internet connections
this is true and the government and some
schools have been trying to redress this
but it's not a perfect solution even my
students with laptops are losing the
will to live the longer this goes on I
can't blame them in teenage bedrooms all
over the country right now parents may
fancy their kids are doing their
economics work on income inequality but
they're not they're on for tonight the
damage done to students mental health is
less well chronicled but no less serious
i phone a teenage boy to find out why
he's done no work is 3 p.m. and he's
still in bed his once upon a time cheery
voice is flat and he talks slowly and
monosyllables adolescence is rubbish at
the best of times but try doing it in a
tiny impoverished flat with no outdoor
space nowhere to go no one to see and
nothing to do with the guilt of those
god-awful slides on Google classroom
hanging over you all of my teacher
acquaintances report conversations like
this one and worse in longing for
schools to go back
i'ma odds with some teaching unions and
teachers I don't blame them for their
reticence fear of infection is something
we all experience differently and I'm at
one extreme of the spectrum all along
I've wanted schools to open earlier and
for more students not because I'm an
evil lockdown skeptic who puts the
economy above lives but because I'm
daily aware of the damage done to some
students to their education mental
health and chances of a decent life
throughout Downing Street has done a
rotten job in balancing these risks its
communication has been so patently
diabolical there's no point in going
over it again here what is attractive
less notice is its message about the
purpose of school
in given priority to the students who
are soonest to set GCSEs and a-levels it
is implicitly saying exams at the point
of education this is both depressing and
wrong exams are not the point of
education they are evidence that you've
acquired some the students who returned
this week will be learning how to answer
a nine mark exam question rather than
being taught anything of interest the
coronavirus should have been an
opportunity for people in education to
think about what matters we've missed
that chance while the government has had
a rotten crisis teachers have had a good
one whatever the Daily Mail might claim
overnight with no warning and no
training the entire profession has
shifted from whiteboard to wireless in
my old life as a journalist at the
Financial Times it took me five years to
get used to the move from print to
digital and despite a good deal of
training I still bitched and moaned when
I became a teacher three years ago I was
a dinosaur in technophobe but even I
have just about mastered Google
classroom zoom loom and the particularly
dastardly Google Forms with little
training and not much complaining we've
all proved that it's possible to offer
some sort of education online some
schools are doing this brilliantly but
even the ones who have dragooned pupils
into sitting through five hours of zoom
a day can't touch the real thing there
is an irreplaceable magic of a live
lesson with its ability to motivate
cheer and inspire a friend was
documentary maker turned teacher
is hatching a plan to carry out a
hundred desks into a park place them two
metres apart and teach Macbeth through a
megaphone I hope she pulls it off the
only you the biggest teacher's union
last week put out a plan for closing the
gap with lots of good ideas in it
including opening libraries and theaters
and other spaces for students to learn
in but there was a phrase in the
document that filled me with dread
blended learning by next September we
may be teaching small classes and school
and doing online teaching simultaneously
I hope it doesn't come to this I really
do there was only one shred of comfort
in this crisis four years ago when I set
up now teach a charity to persuade older
people to retrain as teachers I didn't
think it would take a pandemic to do my
PR work for me possibly it's the
experience of home schooling children or
possibly it's the way most other careers
now seem precarious or pointless
either way professionals are queuing
round the block to become teachers at
each of our recent packed information
evenings held on zoom' I've told
teaching hopefuls what locked down has
taught me it's not that education
matters more than anything on earth I
knew that already but that old-fashioned
schooling is the best way of delivering
it in the last few months we've seen
what happens to students especially
vulnerable ones when you take away
routine social interaction detentions
and school dinners I'm not poor or
disadvantaged I don't have special needs
I do have a functioning laptop and
internet connection and I'm not 15 but I
want my school life back too